[MUSIC PLAYING]
ZACH CASPER: So my
name is Zach Casper.
I'm a product manager
on the Kubernetes team.
Happy to talk with
you this morning.
With me today is Ruxanda
Danetiu and Shoucong Chen.
Ruxanda is a product manager
on our Stackdriver team
and Shoucong is a technical
lead on Kubernetes monitoring.
So hopefully, we
will go through--
actually, I want to
go back real quick.
Hopefully today, we're
going to talk to you
about hybrid observability.
We're going to cover
a couple of things.
So one is, I want describe for
you how we think about hybrid--
how we think about hybrid
observability, specifically.
And then I want to spend
about five minutes or so
talking about Kubernetes
internal monitoring, how
we use the system metrics
to actually run the system,
and then how does that impact
your application monitoring.
We'll walk you through a couple
of different scenarios on GKE
On-Prem specifically.
We really want to
focus on how this
works in the on-prem
world, and so there's
multiple different
patterns there.
And then I'm going to hand it
over to Ruxanda and Shoucong,
and they're going to
walk us through a demo.
So how does that sound?
It sounds OK?
OK.
So I talked a little
bit about who we are.
I would love to know a
little bit about yourselves.
So maybe I could see some hands.
How many people are
running Kubernetes today?
OK.
So that's most
people in the room.
Great.
How many people are running GKE?
OK.
Still, most people in the room.
How many people are
using Stackdriver
with their GKE environment?
OK.
About half.
That's pretty good.
And how about Prometheus
and Grafana users?
OK.
That's probably
about 2/3 of you.
OK.
Good to know.
I think we'll have something
interesting for everybody here.
All right.
So let's get started here.
And this is how I think most
Kubernetes deployments look
like.
If you're running
in the cloud, you're
typically using the logging
and monitoring tools that
come with that cloud platform.
So for us, that's Stackdriver.
If you're running
on premises, you're
probably running Elasticsearch
with Kibana, Prometheus,
and Grafana.
So two very different tools
for two very different
environments.
What we want to
envision is a world
where you have a
hybrid solution that
is consistent
across on premises,
as well as in the cloud.
So the way we think about hybrid
is, it's the same tooling--
it looks the same,
it behaves the same,
it's in the same
screen, particularly
if I have workloads running
in both different locations.
And so Kubernetes actually
gives us the ability to do this.
The whole point
of Kubernetes was
so that we can abstract
away the infrastructure,
so we can have a consistent
environment no matter where
it's running.
So we have this amazing
opportunity with Kubernetes
to do this.
And so hopefully, we'll present
a couple of different patterns
to do that.
But the way we
think about it is we
look at Stackdriver as the core
piece that can stitch together
to give you a on-premises view,
as well as a cloud-based view
of your workloads.
But before we get too
much into the specifics,
I want to take a step back and
talk a little bit about how
Kubernetes internally works.
So we have all these components
that rely on system metrics,
such as the horizontal pod
autoscaler, the scheduler.
We need to understand
your resource utilization
on your nodes for the
scheduler to work.
We need to know system
metrics for the kubectl top,
so you can see all the resource
usage across the cluster.
But Kubernetes doesn't give
us a sophisticated logging
and monitoring system
out of the box,
but it does have these
system level components.
So this is implemented with
the metrics API and the metrics
server.
And so these two
components work--
the metric server is
actually going and scraping
the system level metrics
from each individual node
and then publishing that up.
So let's take a look at
the nodes themselves.
So on the nodes, obviously
we have the kubectl,
and then we have cAdvisor.
How many people are
familiar with cAdvisor?
A decent-- maybe a
handful, maybe 10 or so.
That's good.
So cAdvisor is a resource
usage collector for containers.
It goes in, it auto discovers
all your containers,
and collects CPU, memory use,
network storage, et cetera.
So the cAdvisor and the
kubectl, they work together.
These two components gather
all the metrics from the nodes,
and publish those
through the summary API.
But going back to our bigger
picture, that cAdvisor
and the kubectl, this is what we
call the core metrics pipeline.
This is a core concept
inside of Kubernetes itself.
But this is just for Kubernetes.
This has nothing to do with
your application workloads.
This is all just the
internal workings.
So for my applications,
I actually
need a third party
monitoring solution.
So this is where we get to--
now we need to talk about,
OK, well, for GKE On-Prem,
what do we use for that third
party monitoring solution?
So let's take a look at that.
What we want to do
with GKE On-Prem
is get you the
flexibility that you want.
We want you to
use the right tool
for whatever your purposes are.
So let's take a couple
different scenarios.
So maybe you have
GKE On-Prem, and it's
running your front end.
And the back end is
somewhere off the cluster,
and you want to have end
to end visibility for that.
So maybe you want to use an
existing Splunk environment,
or maybe you want the
ease of a fully integrated
cloud-based monitoring system.
Stackdriver may be a
great option for you.
Maybe you're interested
in running workloads
in GCP, as well as on premises.
Then you need that view across
both different environments.
So we want to get
you the flexibility
to use whatever
tool you're used to.
So a couple of things.
So Kubernetes out of the box--
GKE On-Prem out of
the box, rather, it
comes pre-configured
with Stackdriver logging
and monitoring.
We're also shipping a
Prometheus and Grafana
instance that's tailored
specifically for GKE On-Prem.
And I'll talk to you a little
bit about what we've done.
Then we're working with our
partners, Splunk and Elastic,
to make sure that all these
systems work well together.
All right.
So let's dive into
Stackdriver just a little
bit, and then I'll cover
the Prometheus and Grafana
at the end.
So we're using three
different APIs here--
three different
Stackdriver APIs.
The first one is monitoring.
So running on the cluster, we
have a Prometheus collector.
We have a pod that's called
the Stackdriver Prometheus
Kubernetes Pod.
And inside of that, we
have Prometheus running.
That's configured specifically
for collecting the Stackdriver
metrics.
Next to it is a pod, we call
it the Stackdriver collector.
So it's extracting
the Prometheus metrics
and shipping them over to the
Stackdriver monitoring API.
We've done a couple of things
here on the Prometheus instance
to make sure it works
well in GKE On-Prem.
So we're doing things
like, we've expanded
the duration of the buffer.
Because we want to make sure
that, in a network outage,
that the metrics are whole
inside of Stackdriver.
So we've expanded
the buffer there.
A couple of other
things like that.
Now, this Prometheus
instance, this isn't something
you need to configure
or worry about.
This is really just an
implementation detail.
So next, we have the logging.
The logging is pretty
straightforward.
So we have a logging agent
running on each of the nodes.
Those are aggregated up
into a logging collector.
It just so happens that we're
using Fluent Bit and Fluentd.
Fluent Bit for
the logging agent,
and then Fluentd
for the collector.
Again, that's just an
implementation detail.
The last piece is
the metadata agent.
So metadata is pretty
important to us
because we want to give you a
better experience, rather than
just straight logs and metrics.
So with metadata, we
can stitch together
into a much better visibility
across the cluster,
because we actually have
some knowledge about what
is actually running
on your cluster.
So with these three things--
so we have logs, metrics,
metadata--
these three things will give
you a much better experience.
The last thing--
I want to cover
Prometheus and Grafana.
So not everybody wants to
use, necessarily, Stackdriver.
Pretty much everybody that
raised their hand when I said,
who's using Prometheus
and Grafana.
So we're shipping Prometheus
and Grafana with GKE On-Prem.
We've done a couple of things
to make sure it works well
inside the environment.
The first thing we
wanted to do was
we wanted to give you
a multi-cluster view.
Because with GKE
On-Prem, you're going
to have multiple clusters.
Out of the box, you have
an admin cluster and a user
cluster.
So what we've done is
configured Prometheus
to have a multi-cluster view.
And you can choose the scope
that you want to look at.
So if you want to see the
multiple cluster view,
you can use the
Grafana instance that's
running on the admin cluster.
If you want to see just
the user cluster-- so say,
for example, you have an
application specific cluster
and you want to give that
out to an application team,
they can use that
Grafana instance.
Then lastly, for those that
really enjoy using Grafana,
you can actually
build dashboards
that look at both the
Prometheus data for GKE On-Prem,
as well as data from
your GKE clusters.
Stackdriver is a native
data source for Grafana,
and so you can have
a dashboard looking
at both different clusters.
All right.
So that wraps it up.
That gives you just
a general overview
of where we're at
with GKE On-Prem.
So a couple of different
options just to review--
cloud-based out of the
box with Stackdriver,
and then certainly Prometheus
and Grafana, as well as
our partners.
So with that, I'm
going to welcome up
Ruxanda and Shoucong, and
we'll walk through this demo.
[APPLAUSE]
RUXANDA DANETIU: Thank
you so much, Zach.
So next, we're actually going
to go through the project.
So we're going to
actually look at how
this works and integrated
with Stackdriver.
So for the purpose of this, we
actually built a demo project.
This is the Petclinic.
Adorable pictures
always work at demos.
The concept behind these is that
you have a series of owners.
So let's see who we
have in the owner list.
And we're going to try to figure
out if Shoucong is on the list
here, and see if we
can add a pet for him
so you can have an idea of
how these services look like.
And while Shoucong
does that, let's
talk a little bit about what's
happening on the back end.
So we're going to have
two clusters here.
One cluster is going to run
on GKE and on the cloud.
And one cluster is
going to be GKE On-Prem.
And in this
scenario, we're going
to have the API gateway
with three microservices
in each location, and we're
going to push all of the data
to Cloud Spanner it on
GKE so we can actually
monitor both the GKE cluster
that's running on cloud
and the GKE cluster
On-Prem within
the exact same visualization.
So once Shoucong
has completed this,
we're going to go and
see how we can actually
get access to this information.
And throughout the
demo today, I'm
going to show you three main
pillars of the experience you
get in Stackdriver.
The first one is going to talk
about Kubernetes monitoring out
of the box, and this is a beta
product that we have launched.
The second one, what
we're going to talk about
is going to be around
the custom experience
that you can actually build.
So you can do your own
custom dashboards as well.
And then we're going
to talk about alerting.
At the end, Shoucong
is going to take over,
and he's going to give us the
idea of how you're actually
doing a troubleshooting.
So right now, we're
going to add some load--
we're going to generate
some load to this app
in order to be able to
see some alerts firing
and how we do the
troubleshooting
towards the end of the demo.
So he's doing this right now
in the GKE console for the GKE
cluster that's running on GCP.
You can see the two
clusters right there.
And then he's going to do the
exact same process for the GKE
On-Prem cluster as well.
Wonderful.
So let's go to the
Stackdriver UI.
As we're going to the
navigation within Stackdriver,
we can select
Kubernetes Monitoring.
This is the experience
that I mentioned before.
It is an out of the box
experience for all users
of Kubernetes and GKE.
Right now, as we
are selecting this,
this is a beta product
for Stackdriver.
Everything that you
see on this page,
as long as you're using
GKE exactly as Zach
mentioned, all of these
do not require a setup.
Everything gets collected
and gets reported for you.
So we have those two
clusters, one is on cloud
and one is on prem.
And I want to give you a
tour about the capabilities
that you're getting
on this page.
So at the top of the page,
we have the alert timeline.
What we think is extremely
core to the experience is
to know when things
get alerting,
the troubleshooting
workflow is fundamental.
And here, we want to actually
showcase all of the alerts
that you have within your
Kubernetes environment that
span both cloud and on prem.
So if you hover
any of these cards,
it's almost like a heat map.
The more alerts you have,
the darker the shade of red.
And you get information about
the alerts that have fired.
Underneath this, we have these
three tabs, Infrastructure,
Workloads, and Services.
And we spent a lot of
time talking to customers
and getting to understand
what are the different flows,
personas, and use cases.
And we realized
that in some cases,
operators and developers
may have different interests
or entry points.
So we built these
three different tabs
to satisfy somebody that's
really interested in focusing
on nodes and clusters and
an infrastructure approach,
but we also want to
cater to developers
that are more interested
in deployments and services
as well.
So this gives a
quick entry point
to all of those experiences.
We are starting with
the infrastructure tab.
And the two clusters
are, as you can see here,
we are going to open a GKE
cluster running on cloud.
The table itself has almost
a hierarchy built into it.
And while we know that
Kubernetes and GKE does not
have a hierarchy, per
se, but the metadata
allows us to read
all of these labels
and actually build
an intuitive way
of reporting this information.
So you can see your
cluster, the nodes in it,
the pods within that node,
all the way to the container.
And this level of drill
down can be really helpful
as you're trying to
do troubleshooting
or you're trying to
find particular things,
so you have the groupings
to help you to navigate this
really easily.
At the same time,
the table itself
gives you at a
glance information
around the resource, the
number of pods that are ready,
the number of incidents, the
CPU utilization and memory.
On the workloads page,
we have a hierarchy
that spans clusters,
namespaces, deployments, pods,
and containers.
So you see that there
are different ways where
things can get clusters,
and the hierarchy is really
important as a way of
getting to the drill
down that's more
significant to the workflow
that you're interested in.
And we have-- let's pick for
the API gateway for deployment.
Let's click on one
of those and actually
look at some of the
details of a pod.
So for every single
entry within this table,
you get the details panel
that gives you information,
gives out of the box metrics
that are already created.
You get these charts
pre-populated for you.
So it requires no setup.
We have an integration
with logging as well.
So you're going to
get a high level
histogram of the logs
for this particular pod,
and you're going to
get a selection of logs
filtered by severity
for this pod as well.
And of course,
that's never enough.
So you're going to be
able to very quickly click
on the entire
logging experience.
The context is going
to stay the same.
So here, we are in the full
logging experience in the GCP
console, but we are only looking
at that particular cluster,
at that particular pod
that we are evaluating,
and that particular time span.
So you can go and end up doing
your troubleshooting there
and do more filtering.
And then we have details
information as well.
So as we are going through
all of this information,
the details are
really important,
and you're able
to go and get logs
and metrics for every single
entry within those tables.
And of course, we have a deep
integration with the Kubernetes
and GKE teams.
So you can go in
and actually get
a lot more detailed information
from the GKE page in context.
So when we go back
to Stackdriver,
we can actually see the
third column is Services.
This gives you an
ability to actually
go through the entire hierarchy
with services as well,
and gives you information
within the same span
of cluster, namespace,
service pod, and containers.
So let's go back to
infrastructure for a second.
The table itself has
an embedded hierarchy,
and it's interesting
to navigate.
But one of the things that is
sometimes problematic, when
you have hundreds
of these entities,
it's really hard to
understand patterns
and being able to come up
with insights of the way
that, maybe, there is a trend
out there that you're not
able to see in a table format.
So we build this
bubble visualization,
mostly because we really
like bubble visualizations.
No.
But the idea is that it's going
to empower you to use metrics.
So we have a CPU
usage on the x-axis,
and on the y-axis, memory usage.
Each bubble represents a node.
The size of the
bubble represents
the number of pods in that
node-- so how big the node is.
And then the color
represents the health.
So if it's a light gray,
it means that it's healthy,
and red means that
it's an incident.
And as you can see, there are
all of these different clusters
that are forming, there
are all of these patterns
of information.
This is an exploratory
tool that we're
launching in beta as well.
And we are trying to make
this as a way of using
the data that you have, the
information that you have,
and come up with interesting
insights about trends that
are happening across these.
It's important to mention
that right now, we're
looking at nodes that span
both cloud and on prem.
So it's a fascinating
way of understanding
this behavior, where,
at the end of the day,
we want to get to a position
in, especially with Anthos,
is that you shouldn't care if
something is on prem or on GCP,
and you need to have a
single tool that manages all
of these things for you so
your monitoring solution is
in one space.
So far, we talked about
the out of the box
experience for Kubernetes
and GKE within Stackdriver.
And while we understand that
every single out of the box
experience out there is
amazing up to 80% of the time,
and then you're going
to have some use
cases where you're going to
need to build something custom.
So Stackdriver allows
you to get access
to all of this information
and build your own custom
experience as well.
So what we developed
is this tool called
Metric Explorer that
gives you the ability
to actually query all of the
metrics that are coming in--
all of your system
level metrics.
And these metrics come in
either from GCP on from on prem.
You find them within
the exact same space.
As you can see here, there
is a lot of information.
We have a lot of
lines on that chart,
and it might not be readable.
So maybe we want
to apply filtering.
So you can benefit from
using advanced filtering.
At the same time, we
can group things by,
we can add a lot
of functionality
and aggregate this
information as well.
And one of the things that
we build is that sometimes--
we try to do a
good filtering, we
do a good job of bringing
in a lot of data.
But it's too much data
to make it meaningful.
So we've introduced
modes and options for you
to do an outlier
mode, so you can
pick to always show the top
five outliers within your space,
or top 10, or top 15,
the number that you care,
and make these charts
really meaningful for you
when you go in to know
where the problems are,
so you can investigate
a lot faster.
And as you can see here, there
is a lot of trial and error.
So we can spend
quite a few minutes
until we figure out what
are the right metrics, what
are the right filters, until
you build your great chart.
And you don't want to do
that every single time you
log into Stackdriver.
So we have the
ability for you to be
able to save these charts, and
save them in a new dashboard,
add them to an
existing dashboard.
These charts can be easily
shared through your URL
with all of your colleagues,
so you share the same context.
So let's look at
a custom dashboard
next so we can actually
see this capability live.
This is a hybrid dashboard,
so every single chart
that you see on
this graph displays
data that is collected from
both Cloud and On-Prem GKE.
So a lot of this information
is being brought to you
in one single dashboard.
You don't have to create
multiple dashboards,
you don't have to go
to multiple consoles
to have different experiences.
Everything can
come in one place.
You can easily add more charts
and make this customizable.
And then you can easily
play and delete things,
so you can make this space
really meaningful to your team.
We talked about the
custom experience.
Next, I want us to focus a
little bit around alerting.
We know at the end of the
day, monitoring proactively--
it's time consuming,
it's something
that you won't be able to
just spend all of your day
looking in front of
a screen and waiting
for something to go wrong.
So we need to be really
smart about our alerts.
So we created an integrated
alerting experience.
So let's try to start the
process of creating an alert.
As you can see, the interface
that you have access to right
now is the same interface
that we showed earlier, is
the Metric Explorer Interface.
You have you have the ability--
once you get to know the system
and start playing with
Metric Explorer, that
is the one-stop shop for
creating your dashboards,
creating your alerts.
You're using the same workflow.
We want to make
sure that you don't
have to have a ramp
up of learning curve
for each and every experience.
So you have the exact same
metric capability, filters,
all of these things are brought
in within the same workflow.
So of course, you
can edit these,
you can add notifications, you
can add critical documentation.
These are really important.
We really encourage
all of our customers
to use documentation
heavily in their alerts,
and link to dashboards, and
provide links to books as well.
So let's look at some of the
incidents that we just created.
So these will be displayed,
so you can actually
have a list of all
of your incidents.
And these can span
alerting policies,
and these can span both
the environments that you
have on cloud and on prem.
And now that we've covered--
just to bring
everything together.
We talked at the beginning about
the out of the box experience.
We're hoping that that
experience gives you an option
to have visibility without any
setup and be able to sustain,
probably, the large
majority of the use cases.
Then we talked about
the custom option.
If you want to build your
custom dashboards that
are hybrid, that
span both clouds,
you have that option as well.
And how to build a really,
really smart alerting
that can help you navigate
how not to get woken up
at 3 o'clock in the morning.
But because we
created these alerts
and we added some
load to the app
at the beginning of the demo, I
think Shoucong just got paged.
And he's going to show us what
happens once you get an alert,
and how we troubleshoot this.
So Shoucong.
SHOUCONG CHEN: OK.
Thanks, Ruxanda.
So this is Shoucong.
I'm going to give you
a demo about where
a typical, classical
troubleshooting
scenario in our daily work.
So as a SWE--
so we're usually
[INAUDIBLE] is that when
your application becomes more
and more used by customer,
you're receiving more
and more traffic.
And in the meantime,
some of your server
become slow and unresponsive,
and it's usually the moment
that some on-call
engineer were jumping
and they figure out
what's happening.
And we want to understand,
is it due to a bad machine,
due to a bad deployment, or
due to something misconfigured?
And it's become more
and more complicated,
especially when you
have distributed set up.
Also like a hybrid setup,
you have GKE On-Cloud,
you have Kubernetes
On-Prem, or GKE On-Prem,
and you're also distributed
across many different areas.
That is the scenario
we're trying to demo here.
So as you may recall from
maybe 10 minutes ago,
when Ruxanda
started her demo, we
generated some traffic to
both of my GKE cluster and GKE
On-Prem cluster.
So whilst she is demoing,
as the on-call engineer
of this Petclinic website,
I have been paged.
So this is the
alert I've received.
Stackdriver sends me an alert,
talking about something--
HTTP sever request count
for 500 is too high.
And based on the documentation,
I know this means too many--
500 has been returned
for my services.
This is a little bit concerning
to me because returning 500
means my customer may be
experiencing this outage now.
So let's take a look at
what incident detail page
Stackdriver tells me.
So as you can see
here, we are receiving
around 12 requests
per second of 500
for the service API gateway.
This is a little
bit concerning to me
because API gateway is the
interface of my application.
So as a SWE, I go to the
predefined custom dashboard,
which has almost all of
the important metrics
I'm curious about
my hybrid setup.
So as you can see on
the top two charts--
the first chart on the top left
corner, this is the hybrid--
the request counts go to both
clusters in my hybrid setup.
As you can see, I receive
around 150 requests
go to my GKE On-Prem cluster,
and then around 200 requests
go to my GKE cluster.
This is working as intended
because this is how
my load balancer configures.
So let's take a look
at the top right chart.
So this is the error rates.
So from this chart,
it's giving me
a very strong signal that
something is wrong in my GKE
On-Prem cluster.
Because we can see
here, all of the 500
are coming from my
GKE On-Prem cluster.
So as a developer,
my first interaction
is I tried to dive into
this GKE On-Prem cluster
to debug what the issue will be.
But as the Google [INAUDIBLE]
best practice tell me,
the first thing I need
to do at this moment
is to mitigate the issue.
So one of the various
classical ways,
we just [INAUDIBLE]
this GKE On-Prem cluster
and failover the
traffic to GKE cluster.
Before we do that, I
have one more thing
I want to confirm for
additional safety.
So let's go to Kubernetes
monitoring view.
The thing I want to
confirm is, if I fail,
that means my GKE
cluster will receive
the double size of the traffic.
I want to make sure my GKE
cluster can sustain the load.
So that's why I come to
these infrastructure view.
As I can see here, CPU and
memory usage for both cluster
are around 20%.
If I expand the GKE cluster,
I see there have six nodes,
and each of the nodes is
running around 20% CPU
utilization and around 20%
to 30% of memory utilization.
So you still have plenty of
space, so I can failover.
I think that's a safe
move at this moment.
So let's go to this
GKE On-Prem cluster.
I just ran the traffic
into this cluster.
And then I go to this
Kubernetes cloud SS edge,
and then I just double the size.
This is to simulate
the failover.
So in real world, we will
have more of the ones load
balancer configure will do.
But in this demo, we just
simulate it this way.
So as we go back
into this dashboard,
usually the load balancer will
take around one or two minutes
for the traffic to migrate.
So eventually, we will
see the On-Prem cluster
traffic goes down, and then
GKE cluster traffic goes up.
But we will not wait the
time here to wait for that.
We will go back after
I finish my demo
to verify this is the behavior.
So I believe the current
outage is reasonably mitigated.
As a developer, I want to debug
the root cause of the issue.
So that's the moment I
go to my Service tab,
because that's the
thing that is alerting.
I see this incident color
has given me very good hints.
Something is wrong
in On-Prem cluster.
This is another way we
can narrow down the issue.
And we go to this incident
color keep telling me
where I should focus
my attention to.
So this is the API gateway.
I should take a
look at this part.
So let's open this
detailed view.
I see there's an open incident,
and there's too many--
500 has been returned
from this container.
Let's look at the metrics
for this specific path.
As you can see,
container restart--
there's nothing restart,
which seems great.
Memory utilization is flat
because this app is not
memory heavy.
Also, data is starting
in the Cloud Spanner.
For CPU utilization, we see
from around 15 or 10 minutes
ago that have some CPU spike.
That's expected because we
generate a lot of traffic.
Storage usage is
also flat because we
don't write anything.
Network usage is high.
This is also caused by
the traffic increase.
So just looking
at the metrics, it
seems everything
is looking great.
It means my Kubernetes
infrastructure
is running healthily.
Then what could
be the issue here?
At this moment,
this is the moment
where a log can help us a lot.
So if you go to the Log tab,
we see the log rates here.
This gives me a very
obvious signal something
is wrong, because my application
is writing a lot of error logs.
As you can see, this is around
40%, or one third of logs
are returning as error log.
This is very suspicious
because normally, we
don't write so many error logs.
And we go to the snippet,
we see there's indeed
some error logs here.
Let's go to logs [INAUDIBLE]
to see more details.
So this is already
an expanded arrow.
For the detail here, we can see
this is Java Runtime exception
have been thrown.
And it gives me the
full stack trace.
So I can go to where the
thing that's happening
in the very concrete detail.
So let's see what this means.
Let's just fetch.
Fetch [INAUDIBLE].
Let's go to the code.
So this is where
my code base is.
So I just do a grab of
a past error message.
I can see this is
something that is
written in the API gateway
controller in Java,
and in line 54.
Let's just open the file.
Unable to fetch.
So at this moment, it's
very quite clear to me
this error message
or this 500 error
has been thrown because
somebody write this line of very
suspicious functionality.
It's basically just like a--
it was occurring before
returning a successful request.
So there's a 50% chance
that you will not
be able to get a correct
result. So here, this moment, we
have already identified
the root cause.
The root cause is somebody
introduced a bug into the code,
and then deployed it into
my GKE On-Prem cluster.
So the next steps for
me are very clear.
I will just fix the
bug in the code,
redeploy into the
GKE On-Prem cluster,
and then [INAUDIBLE]
the GKE On-Prem cluster.
Then we can make our
application back to normal.
So this is the end of the demo.
[MUSIC PLAYING]